a brand has to pay usually Upfront for a
defined scope irrespective of how the
content actually performs which means
it's hard to track Roi and prove all of
that so this actually gives a different
it realigns I suppose the incentive
between the brand which is driving down
purchases and conversions with creators
being able to earn from that point as
well
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today we're talking about the
Creator economy and travel meet Nicole
TJ the co-founder and CEO of Travis a
travel app that turns dream vacations
into a reality while leading the charge
on empowering micro influencers who are
changing how we discover plan and book
vacations before co-founding Travis she
was an influencer who experienced the
struggle and success of building their
brand through Partnerships and affiliate
programs she later worked in strategy
and Innovation Consulting at Deloitte
and she uses her knowledge and
technology and her first-hand experience
of being an influencer to inspire the
mission and consumer goals of Travis
[Music]
Nicole TJ welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here how are
you thank you for having me Michael I'm
glad to be on here today
I'm really excited for us to talk about
you know Creator economy travel your own
personal Journey you've had quite a few
different experiences before
um quitting Travis and so it's going to
be a fun 20 minutes to try to unpack
quickly you know what you've been up to
and then how you're looking at this new
world that we are in and so Nicole tell
me a little bit about you know yourself
leading up to to this formation of
Travis yeah well I'm Nicole currently I
am co-founder and CEO of Travis
um you are right in saying that I've had
a little bit of a diverse background
um years ago I used to be a Creator
myself
um and this was very much uh focused on
lifestyle fashion and travel and then I
also worked um a lot in the influencer
management space managing influencer
campaigns of many sizes
um and a huge bulk of my experience was
actually also working at Delight digital
so strategy Innovation Consulting for a
lot of Tourism Brands and so as you can
see I do have
um I guess industry insights from a few
different facets across the ecosystem
and interestingly how they all come
together with my experience as a
traveler you know how do we actually
find our inspiration how do we actually
plan trips that we want to go on
has been the combination of what leads
to how we're building
um at Travis today
and so what led to sort of the insights
that you have now about where we're at
in terms of the greater economy and the
travel space you know map out of this
landscape for me
so what we believe is that creators are
crucial uh for the future of travel
right
um we are at a point in history where
there's more creators in the world than
ever before creating more content than
ever before and the role that the
playing across Industries but in
particular travel
um has definitely shifted so
um we see that creators not only are
creating content for the purpose of
inspiration you know Discovery and
inspiration but this has definitely
shifted over the last decade to be a
credible source of truths for you know
you know influencing Brands preferences
influencing planning um decisions and
off the back of that influencing where
people spend your money right so this is
um where we see you know the rise of the
influenza actually is also dependent on
a huge shift in trust in where consumers
are willing to place their trust away
from institutions and to the individual
so this is where we see uh you know
there's such huge potential to be able
to unlock the value that creators
provide for their communities and we're
seeing more diversity of communities
because of the nature of the you know
diversity of creators and at Travis we
can also see that the biggest the
biggest pain point for creators are the
biggest challenge that creators face is
not having the ability to
uh make an income or make a recurring
income through that content so this is
where Travis is enabling Creator to be
able to end through the recommendations
and start earning in a recurring income
through content that they're already
creating
so from a conserved Behavior perspective
yes what really has shifted here because
what you're talking about is it sort of
a new
to new Behavior where people make
decisions not necessarily based on
ads or you know or you know ad placement
or just the recommendations would be
here but there's there's something about
Community something about influence
that's happening in today's world that's
that's allowing people to make different
decisions in regards to their own travel
preferences what what really has
happened here that shift and the world
yeah ultimately it boils onto the shift
and Trust right and I wouldn't say that
it's been you know an overnight shift
where oh suddenly everything is near you
know people are looking at different
sources of information now I think this
is something that has been changing and
is already happening
um it definitely not something that's
brand new and people have to pick it up
um and this is something that we see
when people are looking for where should
I be going
um I tried to be spending three days
what should I be doing in there and
where should I spend my money on more
awesome than not
that they look at multimedia they look
at Instagrams they look at put top
um and start to get that inspiration
from that so economics of this whole
Space what's what what how how do how
does this Economics work in terms of
you know the
these creators the consumers
being different offerings that they're
coming into play how does this whole
triangle work
yeah summer the way that the landscape
works first maybe I'll talk about that
and then how we are combating that at
Travis so
um the way that the Creator landscape
Works um so far is that you know it's a
known Factor now that the income is
unequally distributed and the top one
percent of creators earn a lot of the
money right and most of the creators
they do it for free
um it's a way where they are able to
um digitally through social media be
able to
uh create new reach of the content then
that they've never been able to do
before
um one of the interesting facts is that
we went through our research with about
370 creators now that uh of those who
are currently earning any creative
Income At All That Brand deals make up
90 of this income but only about 10 of
the content so what this really goes to
show is that you know there are so much
content out there that is still deemed
really valuable still influencing real
world decisions especially to spend the
money but for creators
um they are missing out on that Chunk in
the Middle where they don't and occur
there's no way for them to earn a card
for from Brands really
um for the fact that they're able to
drive
these uh bookings and so really there is
such an opportunity for us to be able to
enable creators to start earning an
income or to grow their income by having
a new passive and recurring income
Channel
um that's directly related to their
their content already instead of you
know something that's new and unrelated
to the existing content that they're
already creating so the way the Travis
is doing this is one of our core
products for creators is called bookable
links and uh creators are able to easily
create a bookable link of um tell that
they're already recommending to their
creators so for example I might have a
hotel room walkthrough that I've just
shared on Instagram stories or I might
have a 3D itinerary that I'm putting up
on Tick Tock for example
um people come to me asking where should
I be staying where should I go and I
will be able to create the bookable link
on Travis that is monetizable for me as
a Creator when I share that on any of my
Instagram channels or my LinkedIn bias
for example and my followers make a
booking through that
all right the Creator and able to get
cut off their earning and even more so
um Travis works on a way where we enable
both the Creator side as well as the
traveler side of things so for travelers
you know there's a huge path of
Discovery through the the paths where um
you know people are already engaging on
social media and I get to the point
where I see hotels being recommended
right it looks beautiful I understand
how much it costs I can see the room
options from availabilities right from
the point of the inspiration that the
creators have just served me
um but you know I might not be able to
decide right away and make a booking
right away right I might have to think
about it a little bit more decide what
I'm doing over five days find a few
other things plan on my trip and then
decide that I'm ready to book my five
days in Lisbon for example so Travis
actually also enables the creators to be
able to save that from creative
inspiration
um allow travel students that plan their
trips out come back when they're ready
at the point to make that working
decision and still book there and create
as well also in a card of them so I have
a question from a a sort of you know a
landscape perspective you know it seems
it seems to me that a big part of the
crater economy and that and what's
happened here is sort of this trust that
was built between the travel and between
you know the consumer and the influencer
right it's sort of like this really
authentic
non-transactional trust where
um you know I as a consumer I get to to
enjoy get inspiration from and learn
from these creators who are doing this
out of the out of the will of their
heart and their interests and and it's
very sort of pure and authentic right
and and what I'm curious about is as
you're introducing economics into this
into the behavior how does that change
do you think the queer economy landscape
or my my relationship with cleaners now
that we've introduced sort of some
economics into this relationship
yeah if anything I think it will Empower
creators to be doing more of what they
are doing for a longer period of time
um and to create even more value for the
for the Travelers consuming that content
um and the reason why I say this is
because
if we look up the way that you know
influences and creators
um and that role has evolved in a world
they definitely haven't I definitely
think they they are viewed as more
trusted uh sources right now if we might
recall definitely five or so years ago
before the pandemic uh what really
started to happen in pockets in the
travel space especially was I would say
a little bit off a backlash you know
people kind of going influences are a
little bit like overrated it's a bit
transactional actually you know how
likely am I to wear a flowy red dress at
the top of mountain and they're doing it
just because they're getting paid to
travel the world and
um there was definitely a phase where
there was perhaps a little bit of
distrust or people were starting to
understand and you know interrogate more
about the genuine and uh authenticity of
influences there but I would say since
then you know I think the the the pace
of change happened so quickly that right
now
um we have definitely seen a shift away
from that and creators themselves of
different sizes when I talk about
creators
um I mostly talk about micro micro
creators under 100K
um and they are a lot more conscious
about how genuine how authentic you know
they are providing value to their
audiences because
um we know today that consumers are
absolutely critical of that you know and
I think the only way that they are able
to find their Niche and their place
um as distinguishable from another
Creator out there is to actually be uh
genuine who to who they are and travel
it means my style of travel you know uh
my budget of travel uh you know my
preferences in travel and those things
make up what it is
um unique to me as a Creator and
therefore that's definitely through my
own unique distinction that my followers
have that credibility and Trust in what
I do so I guess I would say you know
from a psychology perspective
um there's a lot of elements and
transitions that happened over time that
has led to where we are today and that
building of trust and credibility
between consumers and and creators
um that means that we are in a space
that's more trusted today and more
valuable today than we probably were at
even five years ago so if we're looking
at the world you know in five years now
and we're thinking okay well how does
this whole you know traveling fluence
economics thing work how how do you
envision
you know with Travis and thought Travis
you know how do you envision this
landscape shaping you know in the next
five years where are we gonna end up
um well we definitely view it with
Travis in mind we definitely see a world
which have us in mind where
um you know it grows from what it is
today as it create a monetization tool
where creators can earn from just hotels
to become a platform that becomes a core
part of a creative webflurry and it's
enabling you know more creative than
ever to be able to monetize from their
travel recommendations and when I say
travel
um it grows across a whole Suite of
categories so not just hotels but also
experiences as well as accessories so
like outfits as well as
um you know bags and things like that
anything within a context of travel now
what that really means is that that
enables uh Travelers actually a much
more Consolidated experience as well
right so you know being able to discover
um a suggestions or recommendations
that's already been you know to an
extent that are curated by someone who's
been trusted out there provides a
certain level of credibility for you to
Warrant spending a bit more time to dig
in a little bit more right and for us
our vision is to be able to let
Travelers discover a plan and book any
of your travel needs within the one
place that's enabled by Creator
recommendations right do you imagine any
major shifts that will need to happen
along with these economics that will
enable for this vision of yours to to
come to play are there different you
know big movements or big shifts that we
expect the market to have over these
years
um I think the biggest
um maybe part of the puzzle that I
haven't quite spoken about yet is
probably industry as part of the puzzle
so I've talked about consumers you know
we've talked a lot about consuming trust
um you know importance of creators
playing that role
um that's that piece of this puzzle and
ecosystem is definitely the brands
themselves and I think Brent's coming to
the table and
um you know jumping on the the valley of
this will actually help us amplify it
even more so so what I mean by that is
that ultimately you know the more that
creators have the ability to
you know there's an incentive for them
to earn from the content that they're
already sharing right that actually
means that for brands or a hotel for
example
um hotels are able to get wider reach of
new consumers in new markets that they
might not have ever been able to reach
before
um and instead of how a lot of you know
influencer marketing campaigns currently
work today a brand has to pay usually up
front for a defined scope irrespective
of how the content actually performs
which means it's hard to track Roi and
prove all of that so this actually gives
a different it realize I suppose the
incentive between the brand which is
driving down purchases and conversions
with creators being able to earn from
that point as well amazing not
interested it's a really fascinating
world and you're in
um thinking about how you know people
make decisions in general and how
different people influence those
decisions and how all that plays into
you know something that's really really
big from an economics perspective you
know really technology and shifts and
how companies are different you know
offerings like hotels and different
experiences are are looking at the way
that they are able to get you know in
front of the eyes of the custom of the
consumers and then ultimately the
decision point which I think is just
it's just fascinating and Nicole I
really want to thank you for being here
and for taking the time to to join this
episode with me I really really enjoyed
it wishing you best of luck with Travis
and in general for all of us with this
new Creator economy World it sounds like
it has it's going to have amazing
benefits for a lot of people and I'm
excited to see where it goes so thank
you very much Nicole
mention Michael for letting me um you
know be on here and sharing my story
with what we're building at Travis too